a community gathered to protest against
police brutality
thousands of people led by a grieving
mother of a 17 year old who was shot and
killed by police on Tuesday police
initially said he'd failed to cooperate
when ordered to stop in a Paris suburb
of non-terre his family and friends paid
tribute to Nell at the March
is a young man he's very kind he's not
evil or hooligan what the media are
saying about him is not true his mum
raised him well his grandmother we know
here around the neighborhood she's kind
and helpful she loves everyone the young
men left us for nothing we're not
contradicting the state we are not
contradicting the legal or police
procedure yes he was driving a car
without a license he tried to flee but
he should not be killed police said the
17 year old drove the car at one of the
offices but this video appears to
contradict the police version of what
happened
showed an officer pointing his weapon
through the window and appearing to fire
at close range before the car rolls off
and crashes to a stop
in view of the state of the
investigation and the details collected
the prosecution considers that the legal
conditions for the use of the weapon are
not met
president Emmanuel macron held a crisis
meeting denouncing both the shooting and
the riots that followed as unjustifiable
clearly the emotion that comes with the
death of a young man calls for
contemplation and calm and it's what the
government has constantly called for I
think this is what should continue to
guide the next hours and the tributes
nevertheless his words haven't stopped
thousands of people from protesting what
many say has become a systematic Zero
Tolerance policy carried out by French
police especially against those from
poor and minority communities
officials are deploying tens of
thousands of police across France
including 5 000 in the capital Paris
alone
the police officer involved in the
shooting has been arrested and charged
the 17-year-old victim is the second
person to be killed in such
circumstances this year and the 15th in
a year and a half many are hoping that
calls for justice can finally be
answered as quickly as possible
Al Jazeera
Al jazeera's Natasha Butler has been
speaking to demonstrators in nottail
near Paris and a short while ago she was
caught up in the unrest
well this is the neighborhood where Noel
lived and sitting on top of the van is
Niall's mother you can see her there
with the ponytail and she is leading
this tribute to her 17 year old son is
commemorative large and when you look at
her she really goes through all the
emotions sometimes she looks obviously
very touched because there are so many
people here sometimes she looks as if
she is on the verge of tears because
everyone has come here to pay tribute to
some that was killed during a police
traffic check not far from here just a
few hundred meters away from where this
March is taking place
it's important to be here the situations
lasted too long the same things keep
happening in truth people are sick of it
yet it could have been my son I'm of
North African origin and it's not the
first time this sort of thing has
happened we are so fed up what's
happening now is exactly the sort of
thing that tends to inflame the
situation because the police are fired a
number of tear gas canisters right into
the middle of this crowd as they were
coming to the end of their wall people
coughing a lot of children were there a
lot of families people are walking away
feeling Furious that the police has done
this what the police are trying to do of
course is disperse the crowd but once
again people are saying this just shows
how out of touch the police are to be
doing this on a day when people had come
to pay tribute to this teenager Natasha
Butler Al Jazeera nante
all right we're now joined by Natasha
Butler Natasha you're able to be with us
live uh after you recorded that what's
happening now in not Theo Natasha
well at the end of the March as you saw
there uh people were gathered well on
this Square where I'm standing in the
middle of nog tear and they were ready
to celebrate ready to commemorate come
together when the police fired the tear
gas into the center and I have to say
you know being here it was really quite
uh shocking because there were families
they're very young children and people
were here to be peaceful and the problem
is is that then it really uh then of
course we saw unrest and violence we saw
some people smashing up buildings there
were buildings just out of shot there
that are smashed up we saw uh fires
being lit another car being uh set fire
to just behind them here there are
there's a bit of debris some Stones all
over the place because there were a few
clashes between some of those protesters
and police but it didn't have to be like
that say many people because it was a
peaceful March it was a moment of joy
and commemoration it shouldn't have
ended that way but people felt so
frustrated and Furious that anger boiled
over and many are saying that the police
handled the end of that commemoration in
the wrong way and that's the sort of
thing that happens over and again they
say Natasha the French Justice Minister
said that all of this is about one
policeman not about the police force as
a whole what is the status of that
police officer who opened fire on Nile
look at this stage we know very little
indeed about that police officer only
that he was taken into custody uh after
he shot at the teenager earlier this
week we also know that the prosecutor
here in the Paris suburb of nante has
asked that he be charged with voluntary
homicide not involuntary homicide but
voluntary uh homicide so for the time
being he has been kept in dusk custody
that's what we understand it will last
for a few days and then the process of
course the legal process will continue
and what authorities are saying is of
course Justice will be served and
they're calling for calm whilst that
process is underway
Natasha Butler reporting from notteon
near Paris who've been following
developments throughout the day thank
you very much Natasha
now ENB is the founder and spokesperson
for the anti-police violence collective
disarmole in English that means let's
disarm them let's disarm the police
um you're joining us from Lyon
the French Justice Minister says all of
this is about just one or two policemen
as I was telling Natasha not the police
forces a whole how do you feel about
that
I disagree totally it's like we are it's
already 20 years we're saying that it's
exact it's not the problem of one or two
cops who are like problematic it's like
really a problem of systemic systemic
violence systemic racism inside the
police it's like also the police is like
the police unions and the police in
general is like it's it's a state within
the state since now more than 20 years
so we cannot say that one policeman is
responsible for this we have a huge
increase since several years and
especially under under the macron regime
we have like a a huge increase of the
police murders every year we we went
from 20 to 25 murders every year before
Macomb and now we are around 30 to 35
murders every every year and and why is
that in your view why is that
I think there's there's many many
factors and one thing is that we are we
we never faced like our Colonial history
and we have it's also the consequence of
50 years of neoliberal policies it's all
together and also now we are in a very
islamophobic and authoritarian context
where the government is just putting
always oil new oil on the fire and this
can just not go through and at the same
time the police is like it's it's it's
uh it's pushed into violence by like
really public speeches that are very
offensive and very authoritarian and
also at the same time like the police is
it's constantly like military more
militarized and the the the budgets of
the Army and the defense are increasing
constantly and this can only lead to
such kind of violence and also the new
low because we have this new law from
2017 that allow the cops it's giving
actually giving to the police to kill
and this is the main problem let's focus
on that a little bit let's drill down on
that because this is not a point of
detail it's pretty major right it's a
law that details The Rules of Engagement
for the police and the change the Rules
of Engagement as of 2017 and since that
law we have seen police fire discharge
their firearms more often what does the
law say
this is like before the low there were a
long lobbying of the police to have to
to have a kind to have a new law that
give them another framework for uh
self-defense and then the common people
and in 2017 the adopted finally the slow
that the the police unions were asking
for years and in this low it's written
uh it's giving a list of situation in
which like the cops can open fire
without being uh afraid or scared of
being prosecuted in fact and this is
also this is why we call it license to
Kill because it's explaining and if you
are and this is this this situation you
can just open fire and you will be
covered you will be protected and you
will not be prosecuted and even in this
case when the government now is saying
that the cop will be prosecuted doesn't
mean nothing because in the past also
cops were were prosecuted it's just that
they'll never go to court after the
prosecution and this is the also main
problem this law is is is embedded in
the whole context of giving impunity to
the cops and this law is just very
symbolic but the whole system is made
like this and we have every year new
security laws like giving the right to
the cops to to to to to make violence to
cover their faces not to show their uh
identification numbers and so on and all
these all these measures uh are going
with this low and this impunity context
what would you like to actually see
happen what do you want to be done I
know you're campaigning for the police
to be disarmed there's no appetite for
that within the French mainstream
political parties I know that there's
there there is some uh with the far left
parties but not mainstream I mean not
not macron's party not the conservatives
so realistically speaking what would you
like to see happen
the problem is you know with in this
context like we are in a huge lack of
democratic Solutions and we have we are
at the end of democratic Illusions so
even collectives who are involved in
trying to change the law they don't
believe anymore in this so uh I don't
know what should be like the solution
but we are one of the collectives who
are asking for dismantling the police
and this was a discourse that was heard
in America after the death of George
Floyd but in France it's very still very
hard to speak about this kind of
solution because actually the police is
acting like a criminal gang and we have
to dismantle many many brigades in many
cities because they will there cannot be
any solution without this because we
cannot calm down the police the police
is just going more and more to the far
right and We Know by the election that
60 percent of them they vote for the far
right so there is no solution with this
police they cannot be like uh uh Fair a
fair solution a legal solution if the
laws are giving even more power always
more power to the police and the police
is becoming more and more far right this
is the problem like we are really at the
end of this Democratic Illusions and I I
don't know even how to answer to this
question to be honest
uh well well you gave it a good shot and
we you gave us a lot of context uh so
thank you very much for coming on the
program today thank you for your
insights and your time
thank you